there it is there it is
all right no oh what is wrong with my
camera
are you seeing yourself truly for the
first time oh my god it's a nightmare i
gotta i gotta just show it enough and
then
take it away this is the nightmare wait
what am i doing
uh uh this uh chat
this oh i can't turn video chat on
apparently you have to
do video chat before you get into a game
yeah no
i can back us up because no no no no no
it's fine it's fine it's fine i'm back
in i'm in it to work good
well i'm glad you're answering on behalf
of bob as well mark bob's good
see i i wasn't even here and i'm doing
good you are doing
better than me yeah well he did hit you
with the plus hand was off the keyboard
i guess i'll do nothing then oh good
skipper how good
are you doing mark oh great take
that hey take that
i mean take that i don't think
i don't think that doubles up got him i
don't have that
color have a three oh
[ __ ] hell do you have this color
no it's not the same but i drew with
this color
okay cool um there
my cards are really boring i got nothing
to do mark get him well
i'm gonna get him i just registered
just registered to me what you had said
oh yeah baby
that's the stuff i know right oh
[ __ ] sake thank you mark oh my god i
saved you
damn it
man why would you do that they bluff
sometimes
do they well not with three cards left
well didn't
i uh
good points wait these cards look
different what's different about this
am i crazy yeah they do look different
right what what's happened
now see mark get him i
well i mean i don't want to do this
wait wait wait wait wait okay that's
fine it's fine i mean
there's plenty of sevens left in the
deck yeah i know yeah you really set me
up for this one mark
yeah this is not gonna last long all
right
i got my hand back hooray
that was short-lived me and the computer
are who switched hands after all that
yeah i
sure are oh okay wait a minute
hang on no that's not even a good color
you know what there's nothing good in
this world i'm challenging it
all right that's fair i get that oh look
at those sevens you have mike
there are so many sevens out in the
field right now this is gonna be a
swaptastic game
thank god at least we're all getting rid
of cars oh look a tip
oh no oh my god
now i'm the only one without a plus i
have all the sevens guys
all of them i say you don't have all of
them
but all of them hold on oh you think
you're gonna skip me
but i think i oh you can't jump in on
those
well i guess all right you yeah
you can't blame me i didn't want to do
it oh let's just keep that trainer
rolling
yay
a two yeah [ __ ]
yeah okay hey two there we go
nicely done hero i don't know why i
wouldn't thank you narrator yeah
oh for [ __ ] sake do i bring it around
never mind
you don't have that hand mark has that
hand i don't have that hand what do you
mean i don't have that hand
aren't there plus twos in the head no
not in my hand they went around sure
glow box [ __ ] has it
yeah somebody's got a hand with some
plus twos i know it's probably
gonna play them got it
there really isn't much strategy
oh come on guys man look at all those
cards
stop that's cool not much green there eh
shut up oh come on now
hey man it's just what i have i don't
have anything else and now i don't have
it at all
but no one knows what i take this glow
box
that's not gonna help you oh god damn it
this is this hand
mark get get uh get off
watch this bam oh thank you
uh mark don't get him all right i will
stay the hand
[ __ ] stay the course buddy
he's doomed bobby's dude
oh he's doomed he's doomed he's well
probably he's doing get him to him okay
all right i'll do it yeah
wait what someone could have jumped in
and chose not to who
i felt that pause aha
oh yeah get a mark oh
show you
mark has a really aggressive hand
oh no oh yeah why no not that one
oh yeah it's all fun and games so you
guys have a bad moment oh okay we can do
this get a mark
did you have green oh i guess not
[Laughter]
goddamn it two cards
hey i have no mark has i have i think
you're looking at the wrong number
did anyone see what just happened there
all right let's see what
uh this way oh [ __ ] you
oh god
all right i got a problem for this god
damn it or something like that
right fine that's okay i'll take it
i'm a man i can do it i'm tough
sure sure okay do this again
[Music]
glow box just the gut of uno
no challenge so
whoops can you even see through that
cloud i can't see nothing i could see it
you guys didn't get to see it but i can
see it all right okay
okay all right okay all right
all right yeah i'm fine it's not as wet
as you can what about me
get a mark what am i going to do this
give me mark
there you go get him god damn it see
what am i going to do
whatever this does i don't remember what
that does
oh okay
[Laughter]
good attack mark you got him king of
strategy here well there's nothing i can
do about that sorry bud
we're on the same team still i promise
okay buddy yeah i get that yeah
thank god now i can draw more cards oh
thank god
what do you want man yeah red maybe blue
i don't have any red well
we're about to find out if that's the
case hey all right
i got some of that
get him oh foreign
i almost died in an accident and this is
what you do to your friend
milking it look you didn't even get a
sweet hospital pic well like what kind
of
what kind of what kind of youtuber are
you
i'm giving you this hand before i die
never mind i'm giving it to glow box
right now giving it to somebody
yeah all right okay
well listen wade i'm gonna give you the
opportunity to follow through on your
promise
oh i will oh
i've been waiting for this day and now
your reckoning is here
and finally my revenge is coming to
fruition
um
what color do you are you afraid of he
knows what god damn color he picked the
only
i guessed which one based on your
attitude
likely story oh jesus
apple bottom [ __ ] ball smith
ball smith i was trying to avoid saying
christ and that's what i came up with
yeah man you know i really picked the
wrong color for me because i don't have
that
either that's the problem that makes me
feel worse now what about
this
oh good punch you in the puncher
who okay who are you punching i don't uh
i don't know
box no one oh what a terrible hand in
glove
oh
please be merciful
here i'll get that hand away from a bob
i won't let him do it to you no
okay good good great good good great
thank you for
saving me kyle now he's drawing double
the deck that he had so who knows what's
in there now
i might have made some mistakes ah
wow what the hell's going on over there
oh my god
nothing good uh how about them apples
i like that good apples okay
wow we're gonna get one entire nevermind
no you know what it's okay get out of
here blue nice
oh wait for it yeah oh
double threes i can do that
that's getting spicy in here somehow we
got all the way around to me and somehow
i don't have one of them
looks like um well i hope you don't have
a blue
i don't but oh thank god
yes oh god
[Laughter]
save me he's lying
yeah challenge
how long does that cloud last because
that's been a long cloud how long does a
fart hang around
oh it's gonna be there a while fair
enough at least the way things work in
my office man oh man
there you go
look if bob if it was oh okay you're
right you're right here
wait oh but
oh oh actually that kind of works out
hey that's the one color i don't got
you're oh no oh we're okay
look at you complaining he only drew one
card okay i can complain if i want to
complain hey
come on guys oh you're gonna complain
you gotta complain
come on guys complain someone complains
they don't get a turn oh somebody gonna
complain here bob have a turn that was
really rude
really enjoying this it was a good time
i'm not complaining i would never
complain
wait what the hell yeah did you see that
what was that [ __ ]
that was out here
that's that's impressive the computer's
not even hiding it either
yeah yeah that's that's nuts man that's
nice barbara must be sneaking into these
uh
hey wait a minute well hey wait a m wait
hey wait a minute
what the hell all right i thought that
we were cool but then we weren't cool
how did that happen here bob this will
be pretty cool no
i was just joking oh man thanks though
or
something you're welcome appreciate you
here for you buddy that's
the good stuff right there i just want
to make sure you didn't have to worry
about drawing for a while you got
everything you need right there
good we're really good right now hey bob
it's okay i'll be on your team
can you be on my team are you really
really
i swear i'll be on youtube you mean it
yeah if you just stop bitching for two
minutes i'll be on youtube
wow all right all of you guys it's a
good game
all i need is 30 seconds guys 30 seconds
whoo this is tempting but i won't do it
oh baby no that definitely means you
don't have
i it do it but i do
have that all right bob i
avoided this last time uh no let's do it
oh okay
good we're doing it we're doing it we're
doing it we're doing it we're doing it
come on
you know what man you really are my team
i love you man i love you too man
you've been a good friend of me for a
lot of years thank you appreciate you i
don't tell you that enough but yeah oh
man that means a lot
you're good friend oh oh
okay i still got your back don't worry
about it all right cool cool good man
hey i didn't do the thing i could have
done but let me know when you're ready
to do the next thing we do
yeah hang on i'm gonna need to charge up
some power for us
to do that yeah all in the 30 minutes
we've been doing this
probably not yeah i'm really bringing up
the average here
oh
wow okay oh wow no
no no wasn't it just yellow
oh wait yeah i had just made it yellow
five
this guy's cheesy
oh that's okay that guy's cheating hey
wait you got any yellow in here
oh yeah i do
this is probably the winning half about
my hand don't
oh that's not a good hand to have at all
it's okay hold onto it
think about it good thing don't make any
rash decisions
i i couldn't if i wanted to here let's
leave that dangerous hand in the cloud
okay we can do it mark i don't have the
thing to do it
i only have this no oddly enough okay
not not at this juncture later right now
i must divide my 69 it's very sad
go forth nine tell the world of our
deeds
did you see that you immediately got the
card you wanted
what the hell absolutely absolutely
hacking right now
okay well i did the same thing but i'm
not cheating how is it
deck do i not have anything i have that
that's the hand that
we're starting over yeah well backs for
the start
way back to six cards back to the start
all right
oh [ __ ] you game not a god damn it
i think the game is actually conspiring
against you wait usually i think you're
full of it and you're just being
paranoid this one's pretty blatant
gotta be honest oh i made a mistake
putting yeah can we get a reverse
no there's no way man can we get a
reverse it might work out for you
mark you got some kind of something
doing something
oh i've got something on hey buddy homie
friends
got something oh
oh don't worry round two i'm sure it
can't happen twice
you know what's gonna happen okay okay
that seems that still seems pretty mean
to do to a friend mark but i wasn't
doing it to
you it just happened to you it seems
pretty mean to do that to someone you
would call
your teammate i understand that and wait
do you want to trade hands
all right let's see what happens here
maybe there'll be some exchanges
and now this hand is just as good as
that one if not better i'm really happy
right now
i'm about to be very unhappy though i
could just feel it get a mark
oh i'll get them watch one of these
we're gonna follow up one of these oh
damn it
i got one i got one there's one
i really feel yeah i feel good about
this i feel good just hold on to those
good cards for a minute there
oh no wait a minute wait oh
no no oh maybe
whoa okay that was my that was my turn
george of the jungle noise this one uh
oh not that one
oh said that's a good one i would concur
with mark on the not that one
okay i not that one that exact one again
not that one
that's a good one everyone likes that
one okay sorry
previous buddy but you're cook don't
don't don't do it no they can't stack
those there's no way
can't you i don't know yeah you can oh
never mind
you totally can good thing you didn't
get boned there buddy
sorry brother
there's no room for teammates now i'm
assuming i will get my revenge
interesting interesting interesting
interesting ah interesting card it'd be
a it'd be a shame if i reveal this
toolbox jump in oh go
oh oh god oh
crap he changed it from this color i
think mark
you're good you're good you're good you
made a good choice there
wade kill him
kill him now
okay well that was okay let's get it
right back
wait oh no
wait gotta yeah we i all of us got him
same reflexes make sure that hand was
ruined before he stole it back
thanks you're welcome it's a good hand
watch this um
you know what bob i feel particularly
nice i have your hand back
watching all right well that's weird
thank you appreciate it noise
you ever just lasting oh the cloud is
gone that's right yeah oh god what the
hell happened
well we defarted him defart station
it's always funny because it was stupid
no that was
that was the smartest thing i've heard
in a long time
no validity that's not that was
hilarious
deforestation that's so
good get it mark i can't
i only have the one of those get me baby
all right wait can we leave it red hat
all right let's do one of these can we
not leave it right has him
yeah but i don't like that's not a good
card i want to play a good card
this character oh for [ __ ] uncles
no come on man i think we agreed there's
so many other colors
yeah like red yes reddish red
red or red that's not red that's not red
one of my enemies red there we go
[Applause]
mark don't be a [ __ ] to push this to oh
[ __ ] sake what were you saying
sir
don't be a cocktopus mark
oh wait what the [ __ ] did he just do he
played challenging
you idiot robot okay
damn he's been using those cards with
like technical abilities and i
still don't know what they are or how
they work yeah all i know is hands go
whoo
what a hand for a glow box really
hacking it up over here
well now marcus okay okay
why did i do this to my jump
i was lining it up for you lining what
up my death
me under the guillotine
okay well i can do that why i have that
um let's do that
oh come on man look i i forgot
come on come on man
oh oh no well okay
that's i'm sure you can safely challenge
me there's no way
i'll show you six oh god remember when i
said uno like an hour ago that was a
good time guys
hey i've said uno like twice in this one
that will solve all of this problem
yeah there we go now it's fair fair oh
boy
it's kind of already fair but like we
could bear is fair
it's more fair oh
well actually now or bob now you can't
do what i was going to do here i don't
want you to get below nine marks just
stay there for a minute
fair is fair fair is fair that's a
marketing
oh think about this wow okay
that's fair mark listen
what i know what can i do done i know
i've goofed i know
wait i know i've done some stuff to you
i think we can still be friends okay
well we'll be sure are you sure i don't
know
don't glow box oh okay
okay that's a long pause that was weird
something's happening over there that
ain't right clobox is out here hacking
it up
i will take that do it oh i should have
taken yours
i'll trade with you you want crazies
yeah that's fair trade these little
trades
trades
glow box listen calm down
no absolutely not with you
why would i do that i can't play oh
come on when is my turn look at me
drawing cards over here wade how does
that how do you think that feels
oh finally it's not all about you
yes it is well actually it's not
in my head cannon as to how the universe
functions it does circle me
wait what happened now i don't know but
have a turn bob i i feel like this is
about to be uh
poor i think we'll do this okay
well thank god we're all at least below
four ten
cards eleven god damn hold on no there's
okay
let's just aim that deck somewhere else
all right hey whoa
hey come on now no no
i feel like you deserve that
you have it oh it's all you buddy it's
really nice
that's really nice that's not gonna last
very long is it no it's not
but hey right now i feel something
bob is there something i should know
about that hand like some information
some kind of like identifying
possibilities
it's not that color okay good jump in
don't worry mark i had saved me nice man
i knew what would happen
out played that's good oh okay well i'm
just gonna draw some more cards
apparently
oh i don't know what that one does oh
that's right
uh mark what do you got going on over
there yeah
a green eight and a red one i do not
consent to telling you i don't
[Music]
i get a good feeling about this no one
knows what i have a nice reverse might
be really
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa
but what did you say
this is turning up markiplier all right
instant karma
wow
that might have been the world's fastest
game of uno yeah may have been yeah may
have been
[Music]
you